[موسيقى]
هو عنده العادات والحاجات اللي تربي عليها
وهي عندها نفس الكلام لو هو تقبل الاختلاف
وهي تقبلت الاختلاف هيعرفوا يعدوا اللي
بينهم لان تقبل الاختلاف ده في حد ده
بدايه النجاح
ما فيش علاقه زوجيه اصلا
[موسيقى]
تقدر تخلي العلاقه الزوجيه كويسه مش كويسه
لو انت اخذ واحده بنت الاصول في وقت الشده
تشيلك
هتنجح يعني كل واحد يبقى واثق في الثاني
بس انا شايفه ان دي اكثر حاجه
هو يعني
هو في الشغل في
الماليه في شؤون الاجتماعيه في كل حاجه ده
بيخليها مطمنه ومرتاحه
كلمه السر في نجاح العلاقه الزوجيه
مع بعض علشان الدنيا تمشي محبه الله اكثر
من كده هتلاقي حياتك ماشيه زي الفل انا
متجوز بقى لي سنتين ونصف وعندي مصطفى عمري
انا وامراتي ما تخالفنا مع بعض في حاجه
[موسيقى]